was making content I was teaching
classes live every single day talking
giving instruction talking to people
every single day I've been making videos
for 10 years they were just within like
closed Facebook groups so like people
even hear the demo stuff but like for
five years before that I had a chain of
gyms I had sales consults every single
day and so you have to learn how to
communicate with people and I think that
that was just a rocky cut scene that
only people have seen the end of that
journey and being like man you're so
good at this but it's just been
thousands of hours of repetition even in
the gym launch days I had a call that I
set every single day it was open mic 90
minutes every day that any gym owners
that wanted to hop on and ask questions
that were tactical I would be there just
answer so I got really good at fast q a
because I did it all day every day for
years